why are 99 of movies garbage well you
know sometimes they're sometimes garbage
movies are made on purpose
here's a thought have movies lost their
cool
because television has become so good so
if you think back to
growing up tv was was more restricted
and and everything cool happened in
movies like
kramer versus cramer ooh there were some
scenes that i wasn't supposed to see but
i saw them anyway right
right um now you can see it all on tv
yeah i i do think that television
has succeeded so well when it comes to
you know long-form storytelling i do
think that there is
a bit of abuse in that where i've seen
series that were
six episodes six hours that would have
made a really good two-hour movie
uh but i i think that there's an
appetite for
uh the serialized long-form storytelling
and and
we've become used to that we've become
used to the binge watching
so going to the theater to see
you know a story that's going to wrap
itself up in hopefully two hours
um maybe is not as satisfying and even
you know when you look at
the star wars films or the marvel movies
it really is just
every marvel movie is a continuation of
the last marvel movie in some form
because we know there's going to be
easter eggs
we know there's going to be you know
cameos from characters
so marvel movies in a sense have become
not only its own
genre but you know a
sort of a form of long-form storytelling
with the disney plus
series the you know those kind of
filling in the blanks
between movies um but i think that
television is
is great i mean television is where um
nudity in movies has migrated
there's hardly nudity in films anymore i
mean it's
it's you know you're gonna sacrifice
something at the box office
if you choose to include adult themes
in your feature film being released to
theaters if there's nudity in it
you know um that has migrated onto
television
you know it's a golden as mr skin who
was recently
on the film threat podcast told me it's
a golden age of nudity in television
not so much at the movies
um you know there aren't like the genre
of teen
sex comedy kind of doesn't even exist
people people forget that the original
porky's film such as it was um
yes it does feature
nudity but also there's a
you know underlying message of
anti-semitism woven
within that film that of course no one
remembers except for me
i remember this i don't know why i
remember weird facts
but that but um you know maybe this is
also
why television part of the reason that
television
um in a way is more popular than than
films
i don't know if anyone's ever done this
study i would love to see because i
think box office is isn't a
relevant metric by which to to
look at it's something the industry uses
as a piece of marketing
i don't like that box office is so
important
it tends to be to hollywood because it's
again a piece of marketing my
mother who doesn't pay attention to the
industry whatsoever she knows what the
number one movie at the box office
is because it's used in the marketing of
movies
right but that's not an important number
because that number is
is irrelevant because due to inflation
if adjusted to inflation and you can
look this up
gone with the wind is in the top films
not
whatever the top the purported top films
are right um i
so i you know because we're not privy to
a lot of the data from these streaming
services
we really don't know what is
incredibly popular but they wouldn't be
making so many of these series
if they weren't at least getting numbers
that got the eyeballs they needed to
be somewhat profitable but but we're
we're but because we're as the general
public
not privy to those numbers there aren't
we're not
given other than the people who have
access to those to that data
we're not able to learn the lessons from
that there are lessons to be
learned about the failure of something
like terminator dark fate right
there's a lesson to be learned there i
don't think hollywood's quite learned
the lesson yet
um so
you know uh that's kind of how we learn
right you see what resonates with an
audience
um and box office is one barometer of
that
adjusted to inflation i think is is the
better way to
to report those numbers do you have more
hope for the future of television
or film
i i certainly have hope for the future
of television there are
i think that statistically speaking if i
watch something on television and i vet
that choice
the you know the idea that i'll have a
good experience
with a show based on recommendations
friend recommendations
tends to tends to to hit more often than
not
with the movies not so much with the
movies it's probably 50 50
or less you know there will be a decent
experience
if i know what i'm getting into um
i am a person that does enjoy a good bad
film
why good good bad films
are uh just i mean look
there's a certain kind of television
that is made for stoners
right i mean like i think a show like
archer
that's the animated show archer that's
that's like stoner tv i mean
you know most of the adult swim shows
are for stoners right they're sort of a
good
bat i mean like uh tim and eric their
show it's kind of based on that right so
and there are films i tend to like but i
know that they're bad
uh troma movies uh
you know by lloyd kaufman one of the
longest
you know existing independent film
studios
is trauma studios you know what you're
getting into
you also should be aware that james gunn
from the suicide squad and the guardians
of the galaxy
franchise he began his career at trauma
studios he wrote
tromeo and juliet
so i kind of like if i know it's going
to be bad it's not like something that's
going to change my life
but i will laugh and i don't have to be
fully engaged in it
except for you know maybe the scenes
where there's lots of gore
or violence which you can always count
on in a trauma movie
but that's the place where a lot of
people cut their teeth
is in the exploitation genre
everyone from james gunn francis ford
coppola
ron howard who famously you know worked
for roger corman
it's a place you can play and it's okay
to fail
and it's it's you know and and to learn
the basics
i think it's just as important to watch
a bad film and take the lessons from it
as it is to watch a good film
so the night why are 99 of movies
garbage well you know
sometimes they're sometimes garbage
movies are made on purpose
there's a there's a big business in that
just ask lloyd kaufman
or charlie band full moon entertainment
you know famously done most famously
known for the
puppet master series love the puppet
master films they're
they're dumb fun so
so i think it's kind of like just
knowing what you
you know you can't eat steak for dinner
at every meal right sometimes some fast
food
or quick meals are gonna work their way
in and that's what i consider a bad
movie
i just want to know i'm getting one
unlike
terminator dark fate where i go into
every movie hopeful
going to every movie hopeful it's going
to be awesome
and it's it's not when an artist wins a
razzie
how much of it do you think was actually
planned or none of it
i mean does anyone really want to win i
don't i don't know that anyone ever
wants to win a razzy
um i mean uh
showgirls wanna razzy uh
and and you know i mean that film
actually we look at now there's so much
more going on in that film showgirls
there are bad movies that age
differently maybe they were ahead of its
time they're ahead of their time
like a film like the original blade
runner or a film like show girls that
like there was
much more going on beneath the surface
uh i mean uh the trans community in
particular has embraced the movie
uh showgirls as um
just having much deeper meaning there's
a documentary that discusses this
that i highly recommend that you check
out called you don't
know me no mmi check out that
documentary that's a
a whole um deep dive analysis
of showgirls a sort of re-examination
of that additionally like why there's a
whole fandom
around showgirls which i find
fascinating
uh great documentary that breaks that
apart
um and looks at it uh but we just don't
know like what's gonna
what's gonna age well with time right
like what's going to
defy what will be a cult classic which
no filmmaker wants to win a razzie
or have a film that's called a cult
classic because
both of those things imply that you
failed and i don't think i've ever met a
filmmaker
that tried to make a bad movie
although i will say this john waters has
a great quote about that
john waters said you know if you try to
make a bad film
you can't fail
you